（皆様こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーでございます）
（大変今更なのですが、恋ダンスを踊ってみました）
《東海オンエア》
（なるべく大勢の男性YouTuberを集めて踊ったので)
(よかったら是非見てください）
《さとちん》
（では、どうぞ）
営みの街が 暮れたら 色めき
色めき
《よっち - ボンボンTV》
風たちは 運ぶわ カラスと 人々の群れ
意味なんか ないさ 暮らしが あるだけ
ないさ 暮らしが あるだけ
《ワタナベマホト・へきとらハウス》
ただ 腹を空かせて 君の元へ 帰るんだ
君の元へ 帰るんだ
《ヒカル》
物心
《マスオ》
付いたら ふと
《サンダー》
見上げて
《TAKASHI》
思うことが
《HiROKi》
この世にいる 誰も 二人から
《おるたなchannel》
二人
《PDS株式会社》
から
胸の中に
《ヒカキン》
あるもの
《セイキン》
いつか見えなくなるもの
《水溜りボンド》
それは そば……ゲッホゲホ……（激しい咳）
《禁断ボーイズ・まさき》
いつも  思い出して
《禁断ボーイズ》
君の中に あるもの 距離の中にある 鼓動
恋をしたの 貴方の 指の混ざり 頬の香り
夫婦を超えてゆけ
二人を 超えてゆけ
一人を 超えて行け
（間奏）
《フィッシャーズ》
《アバンティーズ》
（間奏）
《フィッシャーズ》
（ガタン！）
ぺけたん「あああああ！痛ああああい！痛ああああ！」
（やり直し）
（間奏）
《アバンティーズ》
《フィッシャーズ》
（間奏）
《アバンティーズ》
（胸の中にあるもの）
（いつか見えなくなるもの）
（それは側にいること）
（君の中にあるもの）
（距離の中にある鼓動）
（恋をしたの貴方の）
《エンディング》